let's come back to this over everybody x
squared minus 2x plus 4x squared plus 2x
plus 4 okay now you remember really
early on when we set our okay as we're
going through this process we noticed
that there were no solutions to these
guys okay and the way we notice there
are no solutions is because you try try
and try and you can't factor out okay
now there's a quick way to work out that
you can't factorize without even trying
to factorize and it's called here's
where I'm leaning forward we're going to
learn this in more depth letters to
freak out if it's a little bit confusing
it's called the discriminant now what is
the discriminant going to put this into
your color off to the side because the
side note and then we're going to bring
it here when you are solving any
quadratic formula when you solve any
quadratic formula if it's nice and neat
you do your think of a pair of numbers
right they add to this they multiply
this and then off you go okay but when
it's messy and it's messy or there you
know you're going to get our irrational
roots what do you do you can't factorize
so nicely you can't just think of might
be rid 3or it might be root 5 right what
do you do quadratic formula quadratic
formula now the quadratic formula who
remembers where it comes from like where
does this jumble of asian businesses
yeah okay so it comes from this it comes
from this guy but what's the process
what's the process that gets from here
all the way to here it has a name starts
with C it's a phrase we complete the
square you take this guy right you have
to divide through by and you do this
rearranging and crazy stuff and here's
what you end up with it's it's ingenious
right it takes something is quite hard
to do with and it just makes it as
automatic as tiniest releases okay now
here's the important thing on what you
didn't notice about this see this part
that's under the square root this part
that's under the square root is
critically important okay in fact let me
try and show you why it's important and
what it actually means right we put this
all over one denominator because we can
because it's neat right but actually
when you do this whole process you get
these two parts separately you get the
plus or minus part when you take a
square root
you get rid of the x squared and then
you get this part by doing some other
algebra stuff so really it's this okay
and then because I I it's the same
denominator why wouldn't you combine
them okay now I hope you recognize that
there are two parts to this what is this
guy what is that that's the axis of
symmetry that's the middle of the
parabola because every parabola is
symmetrical right which is why by the
way that's why I knew when we were doing
that other one this one that we did this
part and then I did this part but where
is I know this can't be a problem could
be a problem it's not symmetrical do you
see that like it's doing something
different here there's doing that that's
why it's like it might look like one but
it's an imposter okay so therefore I've
got my axis of symmetry there's the
middle BAM okay you add something and
you take it away and that gives you two
roots okay of course it gives you two
birds right let's just picture a really
simple parabola here's one okay there's
your axis of symmetry and because it is
the axis of symmetry you go the same
distance that way and the same distance
that way and it gives you two roots
which is what this whole thing is after
does that make sense that you're still
on board okay so far so good now let's
just think about some things here right
suppose for instance this guy here b
squared minus 4ac suppose it's zero
suppose zero what does that mean about
where the roots are there's only one
room because it's the axis of symmetry
plus or minus nothing right so therefore
with where's the river answer the route
is where the axis of symmetry is one
room right okay let's think about what
happens if this number b squared minus
4ac as it gets bigger and bigger and
bigger and bigger okay the roots get
further and further and further apart
does that make sense okay all right so
we thought that zero we thought that
what happens when you get bigger what
happens when you get smaller answer it
breaks it breaks we thought about this
under domain and range right if this guy
is negative you're in trouble right not
only do not have one root or two routes
that are getting further and further
apart how many words do you have you
don't have roots there's no well no real
roots okay there are no real solutions
to that
so therefore this guy over here this
this number b squared minus 4ac it
discriminates between all the different
kinds of quadratics you have right it
discriminates between the kinds that
have no roots all the ones that have one
room all the ones i have two roots
because it discriminates between them
it's the really important factor we give
this thing a special name we call it the
discriminant okay ah that triangle
illuminating confirms I know you're
thinking it's a triangle because the
Greek letter Z roanoke recovers its
Delta dd4 discriminant okay so so this
guy here right here's what I know let's
think about those three things you just
told me if the discriminant equal to 0
right equal to zero as the first thing
we started with then there is one real
solution great okay yes it's right okay
if there he is i discriminate this
positive how many solutions on it there
are sure real solutions right and if the
discriminant is negative if the
discriminant is negative it's not real
there are no real solutions you'll never
solve that thing as hard as you try okay
that makes it okay now get ready to make
a conceptual leap okay if you don't make
it that's okay just try and stay with me
the next pitch will make sense they'll
just be a still a little bit more
confusing this this whole thing this
whole thing right I want there to be
real solutions do I not right that's the
domain they have to be real solutions so
therefore when I look at this set of
things here right I look at the set of
things it has to be one of these two
cases right I have to get real solutions
because that's what you told me in the
first place that's what I can see from
the graph right so there must be a real
real solutions then this thing must be
true I can put those into one comment
that way i can say the discriminant can
be greater than or equal to 0 if I can
satisfy this right real solutions
this will tell me something about this
okay